Well as we continue with our investigation
of the emergence and development of
the polls we come to the polls that just
to use its proper name is in Greek lock
a dime on the last the demon we say.
And that is the proper Greek name for it.
But the capital city of it was Sparta
and its pit bull were called Spartans.
So it's reasonable.
You know it's OK to keep talking
about Sparta and Spartans.
Now when you come to Sparta you are
coming to a policy that you almost want to
spell it in capital letters
with stars between them.
It's like the pole is lifted to a new
level in the sense of all the sort of
theoretical elements and psychological
elements that go into creating a Polis is
intensified in Sparta to such a degree
that it it seems to be almost a different
thing and it's important to remember
that the other Greeks felt that way too.
Sparta had a special place in
their minds and their imaginations.
They admired the Spartans very very
much because the Spartans carried to the
extreme degree the feeling that the polis
was the center of a Greek man's life
and that it had the virtues that
were associated with the post to an
extraordinary degree.
Now they admired it very very much but
they didn't admire it so much they were
ready to live like the Spartans
because the price was very high indeed.
One other thing to remember as we take
a look at the way the Spartans lived was
that they became a sort of a model.
For the philosophers who came along in
the late 50s and into the fourth century
I mean especially Plato and Aristotle
who certainly had some criticisms of the
real Sparta that existed but who modeled
their notions of ideal place on Sparta
with the variations that
they wished to introduce. So.
It's worthwhile.
And of course it added to these ideas
and feelings about the Spartans there is
the fact that Sparta would emerge in the
6th century as the most powerful of the
police and
the first leader of a lasting alliance
of states which create with the Spartans
as the leading power among them the first
international organization you might
say.
If you were speaking loosely so that
there is a practical aspect to it the
Spartans became the most powerful the
most important state in Greece right down
to and including the Persian Wars.
Well first I guess we ought to take a
look at how Sparta got to be what it
ultimately became.
And once again I have to say that all
we can do is to reason from very limited
evidence better than what we've had up
to now but still mostly from written
evidence that comes from a time after the
facts we are talking about practically
no contemporary evidence although we do
have a bit and the archeological remains
that we do have and then reason from that.
Well of course that lead that kind
of reasoning leads to controversy.
And there are different
opinions about all these things.
Again what I will be attempting to pass
on to you is the most widely accepted
set of opinions about these things but
one cannot be sure that other evidence
might not emerge or new ways of seeing
things might change the picture somewhat.
And as you will see or have seen in
your problems book on one question there
really is no consensus.
But again just a make a majority
opinion as to the question of.
How and when Spada got to be what it was.
So here's the.
The the most common interpretation I
would giving you now the story is you come
into the Peloponnese just at the beginning
of the dark ages and it's before the
Dorian's have taken over so that the
people inhabiting that area are Greeks who
are of the branch of the family who speak
and a keen kind of Greek meaning the
Greeks the language the Greeks
spoke in the Meissen in period.
But.
That's not what they're doing when we
first see them historically and they when
they emerge in the form of the people
who will make the Poles by then they are
Dorian's who have come into
the Peloponnese at some
point after the fall of the
masonry and world.
And in most places almost all places
have become the dominant people in the
Peloponnese.
So.
When you first see anything that is
Sparta we see Dorian's running it.
And we see subordinate Greek peoples in
different degrees of subordination who
are presumably a keen Greeks who have
lost out in the competition and who are
under the Spartans.
It looks like from a very early time you
hear about people called Hell lots and
how to define a hell it is not simple.
Hell lots in a certain sense are slaves
but they are not the kind of slaves we
are accustomed to think about who belong
to each slave belongs to a particular
master they are slaves who belong to the
state to the polis as a whole and then
to further complicate matters.
When we come upon them
functioning although they
work they belong to the state
they are assigned to a particular part
of the farm land of the region occupied
by Sparta which is called Laconia.
They are assigned to that piece of
land which piece of land will also be
assigned to a particular Spartan citizen.
So de facto the highlights are working
the plot that provide the food for a
particular Spartan not for
the Spartans in general.
So that's moderately complicated but
the hell lots are going to be a very
critical part of the story and of
understanding what makes Sparta tick.
Now there are also from the first
time we hear of the Spartans.
There are people living in Laconia some
of them in the neighborhood of Sparta
but.
They're one of their fundamental defining
characteristics is that they do not
live in the city of Sparta.
They are not citizens of Sparta.
They are not what the citizens
of Sparta are called Sparta ates.
They are.
It looks as though they are probably
Dorian's although we can't be sure about
that but it looks as though they are.
These people are called Perry boy coy
and their name means people who live
around.
They live around Sparta.
That means anywhere in the territory
controlled by the Spartans but not in the
city.
And as we shall see they have a.
They are in can. They are free. They
are not slaves or serfs or hell us.
Each man each Perry oil costs presumably
has a farm that he works for himself.
The Perry boy also are engaged in trade
such as it is in Sparta which is very
very small relatively speaking and also
in industry again which is not a big
deal but somebody has to be working the
bronze and the iron and making the pots.
And these people would be Perry or coy
because the Spartans as when we finally
see them in the developed state of
Sparta won't be doing any of that stuff.
When Sparta is Sparta.
The Sparta eights do only one thing.
Well I guess not.
They do two things. They fight.
And they prepare to fight.
That's it. They are soldiers.
They do nothing else.
They have no economic function whatsoever.
Now it wasn't always so.
There is
well before I tell you
the story as we tell it today based on
modern interpretations let me tell you
what the Greeks and the
Spartans said about it.
They said at one point back there in
those early days there was a man called
like Kirkus who brought laws to Sparta
and set up the regime of Sparta as we
will know it in the 6th
and the 5th centuries.
But he did it and there's a lot of
arguing arguing about what his date was.
But if you take the ancient Greek sources
seriously maybe in the 9th century
B.C. This was done and so
it was forever there after.
Well not only is this date not
widely believed hardly anybody.
Any scholar would take that seriously.
And then people do argue about when
would the changes have taken place.
And if there was a like Kirkus when
he would have introduced these laws a
skeptical 19th century
historian put it this way.
He said like Kirkus was not a man.
He was only a god.
That is to say he was somebody invented
by the Spartans as somebody who put
together this.
I myself and you know me I'm credulous
by trade and I believe in the higher
naivety.
I think there might have been a guy
named like Fergus and I think there's a
pretty clear if if there was such a man
he probably proposed some laws which
became important to the Spartans.
But I am not so completely credulous as
to believe the system was established by
one man.
Way back when and it didn't change
because there's a good deal of evidence to
suggest the contrary that
there are developments that
happen that makes part of
what it will be ultimately the first sort
of historical event that we know about
and we think we know about Sparta was.
At towards the end of the eighth century
perhaps in the years between seven
twenty five and seven hundred there was
a war in which the Spartans conquered
the neighboring territory to the west
of Laconia which is called Macedonia.
I hope you're becoming familiar.
I hope you're looking at maps a lot and
becoming familiar with the geography of
Greece and the Peloponnese as you know.
You can notice to the west there is a
kind of a promontory that comes out and
it's on that extreme western side of
the Peloponnese is that messiness is
located and it looks like
it's right next to Sparta.
But it is but this an important
thing that you have to be aware of.
There's a mountain range that
separates Sparta from Macedonia.
The Thai agencies range and it is striking
if you go to Sparta and come up from
the Spartan port of give the arm
and head up for the town itself.
Pretty soon if you look to your left
there is this really serious range of
mountains that makes it clear it was a
barrier it was not something that you
could just think a weight it meant they
were very separate so a Spartan wants to
go to Monsignor.
He doesn't just head west he has to go
north and then hang a left at the when
the mountains have stopped and
go around and come on back down.
That's going to be a very important part
of the story of why Sparta is the way
it is.
But the conquest of Macedonia in the first
messiness in war as this is called is
very important because
now the Spartans conquer.
A very large number of people
whom they turn into hell lots.
These are not just like all the other
people that were living around Sparta who
the Spartans happened to make
harlots lots at an early stage.
This is a whole people with a sense of
themselves who think of themselves as
missing means they are
conquered and enslaved.
And they become a critical part of the
Spartan population from the standpoint of
the Spartan economy.
Essential for the kind of state Sparta
becomes and they are permanently
dissatisfied.
They are permanently angry they are
permanently thinking about somehow getting
free and permanently therefore presenting
a threat to whatever the Spartan
regime is.
At the time.
So that's a very very important
development now probably
before that happened.
The Spartans like some of the other states
send out colonies only to one of them
is out west.
In Southern Italy at a place called Taras.
That town becomes under the
Romans it becomes Trenton.
It's Toronto in modern Italy and in
the Aegean Sea the island of MI loss.
Is colonized by the Spartans and it's
so my guess is they did that as a way of
handling that population growth problem
that was beginning to be felt around
Greece before they conquered Macedonia
and that settled their problem forever
thereafter they didn't need anymore land
they had all the land they needed to
feed themselves and take care of what
they needed and to be farmed by these
captive hell lots and yet.
If we imagine ourselves let's say for
the sake of argument in the years six
seventy five.
It looks as though Sparta has certainly
not yet become the kind of a place we
will see in its full
fully developed state.
For instance it is still engaging in the
kinds of cultural activities that are
characteristic of the other
states which will not be true.
When we get to the classical period two
striking examples are in the area of
pottery where we find Spartan made pottery
painted pottery of the same kind of
quality but of its own unique style as
we find in the other Greek city states.
When you get to the late six and
into the 5th century that's over.
There isn't anything like that anymore.
And so that's a change.
But the other thing that's striking is
that in the period before the final or I
should say the major change in Spartan
life we here we discover poets fragments
of whose poems remain are two famous
Spartan poets of this early period to
pander and alchemist and they wrote
beautiful poetry of the same kind as the
other Greeks that will stop by the time
we get to the period we're talking about
and so the next great historical event
that makes a difference in Sparta is the
second messiness in war.
Which occurs in the years prep of course
where these are approximate somewhere
between 650 and 625.
This happens notice in each
case first and second war.
Our guess is a whole quarter of a century
of fighting that's very important to
realize these were not your typical Greek
War of later years this is not one day
we have a battle and we go home.
This was a campaign that
lasted a generation.
That's how hard it was to
conquer Macedonia and then
in the second Macedonian
war.
How hard it was to put down the tremendous
rebellion that brought about the
second scene in war.
It was a hell of rebellion.
The headlights could not have succeeded
in making this such a hard fight.
Had they not been assisted by
some of the neighbors of Sparta.
Argos you will remember from
the time of fought a fight on.
They haven't been an enemy and
a competitor of the Spartans.
And so the archives are quick to join
and help the it's in their rebellion
against Sparta but so too do a number
of cities to the north of Sparta.
From the region called Arcadia also join
in with the Hellas and even so far as
the north western corner of
the Peloponnese is a town
called Pizer near Olympia
also joins the coalition
against the Spartans.
So you can imagine that the Spartan push
forward created opposition and the hell
outs took advantage of that and join
with the other states to put Sparta in
danger. The ancient tradition says the
Spartans really were in terrible danger.
And it was a very very hard fight.
And what happened was gonna turn
out to be the first of a pattern.
When the hell lots were defeated
in battle they didn't quit.
They didn't stop fighting.
They retreated to the safest place they
could find and they're in the senior.
There is a very rugged mountain called
if soulmates to which is a kind of a
natural fortress and which the hell
that's fortified still more so that they
could stay up there on that
mountain and fight off.
Spartan attacks for quite a long time.
And remember the Spartans are hampered
in this war by having to cope with
neighboring cities battling them as well.
By the time that is over.
You move towards the
ultimate arrangement of life.
In this part of that we will come to know
one set of scholars they probably are as
numerous as any would suggest that it's
only after the second the scene in war.
That the Spartan Constitution that I
will describe for you comes into being.
And probably we shouldn't even imagine
that it was all all the laws were laid
out all the customs were established in
one fell swoop but rather that there was
a basic.
Set of things that was laid out and then
over time other changes were made that
produced what we're we're talking about
so that's why I think we can't accept
that traditional like Curtis story came
down step set up the laws that was that
even if we do accept it like Curtis
who was a kind of a law giver
now.
Before I describe it in detail let
me make a general statement about it.
What is established in this
constitutional ultimate reform.
Is to make Sparta like no other state
in the Greek world and then perhaps well
look like hardly any other states in all
of history and to make it the subject
of attention and interest and and
usually of admiration although not always
throughout the millennia you find when
people know about the Greeks and they
know about Sparta I'm talking
about of course in the West
people philosophers and others are struck
just as Plato and Aristotle were by
certain things about the Spartan way of
life that make them take it seriously
and admire Rousseau was a great admirer
of Sparta for a variety of reasons
but one of the things that is I don't
want you to lose sight of is that.
Sparta becomes a slave holding states.
Like no other Greek state.
Now there was slavery all
over the ancient world.
There was no society that we know of
in the ancient world that was without
slavery. And Greece was no different. But.
In the period we're talking about there
were not very many slaves among the
Greek states as a whole and there was
certainly nothing like what the Spartans
did to have such have a system of life
that allowed the Spartan citizens not to
work in order to live.
No other Greek state would have that.
If you want to think about Greek slavery
in the 7th century B.C. think about
what I told you about
Hansen's reconstruction of
the development of the poles.
Think about farmers who themselves work
the fields and are assisted in their
work in the fields by one
or two slaves that they own.
That's not the Spartan system.
The Spartan system will be Spartans
at home training constantly for their
military purposes never working any
fields never engaging in trade or industry
others doing that for them.
Something that in a small way begins to
resemble slavery as we think of it in
the antebellum south in the United States
where great armies of slaves are doing
all the work and where the
plantation owners the Spartans are.
Don't do any work at all.
But and in the south to maintain the kind
of a military aristocracy of a certain
kind. Please don't push that analogy too
far and I hope I haven't misled you by
suggesting it.
But why do is because it's you.
Maybe that'll help us understand
the Spartans a little bit better.
I remember my old colleague who taught
the history American slavery and so on.
John blasting game said to me at one
point he said when the emancipation came
the slaves were freed
and so were the masters.
And I think that's a very
perceptive thing to say.
They were sitting on a powder keg.
Those Southern plantation owners they
were in terror constantly that if
everything didn't go just right something
like Nat Turner's rebellion would take
place they'd come home and find their
wives and children with their throats cut.
They were in constant terror and they had
to live a life that required all sorts
of things that they might not have liked
to do in order to repress the slave
population on which they relied.
And that is what I want to communicate.
The Spartans after the two Macedonian
wars were in constant fear I think is not
too strong a word of hell out rebellions
which might then be assisted by
neighboring states that were jealous or
disliked the Spartans and its lucidity
says flat out that that's what this spring
is to under an understanding Spartan
policy and Spartan thinking it
is their fear of the headlights.
Most scholars would have accepted that
without question lately some scholars
have come up and wanted to question it.
I must say I'm not at all persuaded
by the new interpretation.
I do think to understand the Spartans
we have to comprehend the continuing
permanent concern about the headlights
as we'll make clear as we talk about some
of the details of their lives.
All right.
Let's take a look now at the
way the Spartan constitution
looked fully developed
and we begin with the training
and education of the young.
The treatment of the young indeed
from the time that they are born
the the Greeks said the Spartans and
the Greeks referred to this system of
training and education as our goal.
Gay Aji.
Oh gee ee
to begin with a Spartan.
Let's start with the men.
A Spartan boy is born already.
The four at the from the very beginning.
This is not merely a matter that concerns
his family his father and his mother.
The decision is to add that as to whether
or not he should be allowed to live.
Is made by the elders of the Spartan
community who examine the child.
What are they examining and for mainly
almost entirely for his physical
condition.
If he is crippled if he is deformed
then any way they will have him put to
death. The child the infant
brand new baby will be killed.
And the reason for that was that
they had a clue about eugenics.
They understood that
healthy children grow up to be healthy
adults who grow up to typically to have
healthy children and vice versa.
And they could not afford.
Was their thinking to have men grow up
who would not make good soldiers because
that's what Spartans and.
Worst of all who would then sire.
Boys who were not good
material for soldiers.
So there you see already something that
was totally different from any other
Greek state. It's not that other
Greeks did not engage in infanticide.
They clearly did.
But they.
That decision was made by a family and
it was usually made by poor families.
I mean that the bad decision to kill a
child was made by poor families who just
simply couldn't afford to raise the child.
But in any case it was as it would be in
almost any society you ever heard of a
family decision not in Sparta.
It was a state decision as to
whether you should live or not.
Well I suppose the child made
it through that first ordeal.
Now he has six years of
more or less normal life.
He lives at home like
any other little boy.
With his mother mostly his business
father I suppose to not so much you'll see
why I say not so much in a bit.
And finally at the age of 7.
He is taken away from home.
Put into a word in Greek
that really that means pack.
Just like the don't it don't the Cub
Scouts call and their little groups packs.
Is that right. Yeah. So.
There they are.
And they are taken away from home and
they live in a military school which is
the only school there
is for boys in Sparta.
Day it is that that school is governed
by a magistrate and it is run by the
older boys.
In many respects when I think about it
it strikes me as being like an upper
class British what they call public school
which means of course private school.
You know the descriptions of Eton and
Harrow and even more harrowing places than
that.
I am sure you must have read novels by
Englishmen talking about their school
days and they each one sounds
like a torture chamber.
Well that's what we've got
here. But what. What one.
The worst part about those schools so
far as I could tell while the other boys.
Because they were allowed the older boys
were allowed to deal with younger boys
the way older boys deal with younger boys.
Badly.
They are bullies they push
them around they mistreat them.
It's it's tough to grow
up in a place like that.
That was what they were up to.
Tough I think is one of the critical words
that you need to understand if you're
thinking about a Spartan education.
But they made it now to the age of 12.
They live in these barracks.
They have a communal life.
They have no nothing resembling
luxuries available to them.
More and more sounds like an English
public school of the 19th century.
They don't have shoes.
They are given one cloak.
Now whatever you may think about
the sunny Mediterranean in Greece.
Go to Sparta in the middle of the winter.
It's damn cold so that one cloak
isn't enough and that's intentional.
The idea is for them to
learn how to bear cold.
They are fed enough of course to keep
them healthy and going but no more not to
satisfy their appetite.
This is meant to make them accustom
first of all make them lean and tough but
also to accustom them to the hardships
of a campaign and basically to make them
tough.
They therefore are constantly
on the hunt for food.
And the funny thing is that the
ethos of the situation was this that
was understood they would try
to steal whatever they could.
So for me to know where they would find
things to steal and how to steal it.
But kids are very ingenious so any way
they would they would be encouraged to do
that but they would be punished
severely if they were caught.
So it turns out the trick was
to steal but not to get caught.
That was also part of the training but
I I always thought that some wonderful
focus of what it was like.
To be a kid in one of those Spartan
schools is revealed by the story that
Plutarch tells.
And it doesn't really matter if the
story is true or not because it tells
something real.
In the telling.
The story is that one Spartan boy had
succeeded in hunting an animal that he
could eat and the other the animal he
caught was a ferret and he would have
killed it and eaten it.
Except that at just at that point the
call was for them to get into formation.
And so he had to immediately get into
formation would've been deadly not to do
that but he didn't want to lose the
ferrets so he tucked it under his cloak.
So there he is standing with the
other boys at complete attention.
Meanwhile the ferret is gradually
eating his way into the boy's side.
Naturally he doesn't even blink because
if he lets on that he did he will be
severely punished for having been
being caught stealing the ferret.
So finally the ferret finds
its way to a vital organ.
And the boy without saying a word
drops dead right there in the ranks.
Now of course the point of that story
is to show how brave and how this boys
were and how tough they were and how
rigorous was the Spartan training.
I always always struck by.
How hungry do you have to
be to want to eat a ferret
but however you see the story you'll see
what the messages might be exaggerated
and all that.
But.
That's the picture that
comes out of Sparta
now they are also in addition they have
given physical training they're already
beginning to get physical training the
use of weapons formations and so on.
But at the same time they are taught what
the Greeks call I think I mentioned in
an earlier talk music.
Hey music.
Music What we call the translation
is music but. It means poetry.
It means poems that are accompanied by
musical instruments and sung but the
words are what matter
more than anything else.
And what the kind of things that they
are taught are moral lessons that are
meant to be the things that they live
by that they are raised by and in a few
moments I'll read to you an example of
the kind of thing that was part of that
musical training of course gymnastics
and military training I mentioned before
the boys until the age of 20 are trained
by older boys or I should say young men
between the ages of 20 and 30.
So this this educational element will
consist of boys from the age of seven to
men at the age of 30.
But the guys between 20 and 30 will be
the teachers and the boys below them will
be their pupils.
Now other elements involved in this
picture there was as you will find always
fine in system where boys are packed
together and there are older and younger
boys.
Hazing is part of this game all part of
the business of being tough and manly
and so on and so forth.
But the Spartans know that wasn't enough.
As we will see what they are shooting
for is not developing not merely
developing individuals who have
the qualities that are desired.
They are interested in developing
people young men who are so closely
intertwined with each
other as to be tighter.
Even I would argue than a family.
And one aspect of this
was very clearly sexual.
The typical arrangement was a young
teenage boy would be associated with an
older man but could be one of the men
between the ages of 20 and 30 it could be
an older man and they
had a formal arrangement.
The older man was what the Greeks
called an arrow rotates a lover.
And the boy was the Roman us.
And that means the beloved.
Xenophon who is an Athenian but who spent
a good deal of his life in Sparta and
knew the Spartans very well.
It is very very eager to tell us that
there was no physical side to this
association that it was purely spiritual
and it was between teacher and pupil
between mentor and the boy that
he provides mentorship for.
But that's all but.
Forget it.
I mean this was very much these were
homosexual relationships but it's the
Xstrata thing to remember is this was
a phase a passing phase that is this
relationship started when one
was a boy and one was a man.
And when the boy reached manhood
himself then he was no longer in that
relationship and he himself could become
an arrow Chase and find himself and
Roman us although it would be very
surprising if he didn't continue to have a
very close friendship and association
with the older man who had been his
rotates and the other thing every Spartan.
Went on thereafter and I'll come
to it in a minute was married.
And was supposed to produce children.
Most Desirable be male children who would
serve as soldiers for them so I think
we should think of this as being all
part of a state system of training and
education to produce fighting
men who would also be
practically all a single family as
close and tight with one another as they
could be because of the quality it would
give to the Spartan phalanx made up of
such men.
I was gonna say the the.
Spartan man when he reaches 20 the guys
that were there between the ages of 20
or 30 are.
Allowed to marry.
But they are not allowed
to live with their wives.
They continue to live in the barracks.
Talk about strange and
peculiar arrangements on the
other hand of course they
had a natural desire to visit their
wives which they could do if they weren't
caught so you had to sneak
away to be with your wife.
But if you were caught you were punished.
Now.
What's that all about.
Well it's it shows you that one of the
main many conflicts that exist in the
spartan system on the one hand you have
to do that because you need children but
to perpetuate Spartans but
also to provide soldiers.
So you have to have that
much normality in the system.
On the other hand you want to resist as
much as you can building a family in the
traditional sense because loyalty to
the family might be in conflict with
loyalty to the polls and
the Post wins that argument.
Because the separation takes place.
I don't know whether the
Spartans understood this or
not but it seems to me is a
psychologically
element in here that might even have
physical consequences for all I know.
I'm thinking about imagine what it was
like when a wife and a young husband and
a wife actually got
together all that time.
I mean there's an argument
for quality as being.
At the opposite end of
quantity never mind.
In any case those are some of the
strange arrangements that were now.
But when the man gets to be 30 he stops
being an instructor in the school.
Now he has his own home.
He lives at home with his wife and if
he has young children but below 7 they'd
be there. And the situation
looks more normal except.
That.
These Spartans men did
not eat dinner at home.
They had their meals
together at a common mess.
Each one of which was called a society
on then that word really means having
food having grain having bread together.
And there were 15 men to
each one of these sit here.
This mess and they together had their
meals together for the rest of their
lives.
There again you have a sense of tremendous
community building unit building.
What is that about the
size of a platoon isn't it.
Or is it a squad squad
the size of a squad.
Everything in this thing is military.
Now think about.
Think about the kind of a loyalty to
one another which we have learned is so
critical to success in warfare.
That came from people who have come
through that system and were fighting as
they did right next to the guys
that they saw every day at meals.
So that was part of that game.
So even when they're grown men and
living at home they are still maintaining
their.
Close quayside familial association
with their fellow fighting men.
What are the qualities that are
supposed to be produced by this system.
Discipline first and foremost every aspect
of your life is governed by the laws
and the customs of the community.
You better conform.
There is nothing else for
you self-reliance strangely
enough because all of
these encouragements to
theft and discouragement to
getting caught have to do
with building the ability to do things
like that social cohesion who can imagine
a system more constructed
to bring about such a goal.
Loyalty to one another whatever
group you are talking about.
But of course beyond that loyalty to the
community at large is implicit in all
of that obedience to your superiors.
Physical and moral endurance
courage and another
quality that is important.
And again something that appealed very
powerfully to other Greeks uniformity.
You are all just like one another.
You go through exactly
the same experiences.
There is no distinction among you on the
other hand and this is what is another
one of the so interesting
contradictions about the Spartan system.
Every one of those boys and then
young men and then older men.
Is in competition for honor.
Every one of them wants to be recognized
by himself by his peers and by his
superiors as having been
better than the others.
The best if possible all of them in
this situation of being friends being
associates being close pals being all
those things being part of a unit and yet
competing within that group for personal
recognition and honor and that is a
contradiction.
And it's a very interesting kind of tug.
I think you know this.
You have to understand that the Spartans
are are living in a condition of
strain.
It seems to me much greater than most
societies impose on people but it's
obviously arranged so
effectively that it works.
You don't have we don't have an evidence
of sort of mass insanity or a great
need for psychiatrists
or anything like that.
If it was an insane society they
were all insane in the same way.
And they didn't know it. And I think
that we have to face that fact.
This is this business of
sameness I think is important.
They referred to one another they were
referred to the men who were had grown to
become full citizens were called Homeboy.
Sometimes people translate that
equals that no that's not right.
It is similar as they
are all like one another.
I think it would have been they wouldn't
have called themselves equals because
there was this constant sense that they
are vying to be the best even as they
are so similar to one another.
The legend has it that when like Kirkus
established the system he divided all of
the land controlled by
the Spartans into 9000.
Patches of land.
The Greek word is clear
ROI singular as Clay Ross.
That was the theoretical thing again.
They were all in this case.
They were all equal in their
economic resources because
each one had a Clay Ross.
Whose food the product of that
Clay Ross was his to deal with.
And of course that amount
that was essentially we're
talking about food that was
being produced on that Clay Ross.
So in theory there's all of this
similarity and Quasar equality but age was
another important distinction
among the Spartans.
As is true in most primitive societies
and the old of the society I think the
truer it is age is given tremendous
respect just by being older than somebody
you are treated as in some sense
better than a younger person.
But.
It wasn't pure age because it's also
true that the Honor did you had gain in
your life.
Would also.
Produce respect and in proportion to how
great had been your contribution to the
state. I don't think they had
formal ways of indicating that.
I don't think it's a question
of medals or anything like that.
Everybody knew in a state of this size.
Everybody knew who was who
and treated them accordingly.
Now.
There were also over time.
There grew up to be inequalities not
only of age and of honor but also of
wealth.
It's a little bit hard to know how all
this came about but at different times in
Spartan history you see there are people
who have managed to lose their Clay
Ross.
And when you don't have a Clay Ross you
don't have the necessary wherewithal to
make your contribution to the society
on the mess at which you all dine.
And when that happens you have dropped
out of the Spartan citizen body.
You are no longer a Sparta.
You are something lesser and that is a
very tough kind of thing for a man to
have to live in as a Spartan.
Now.
Before I get to the
whole hang on a second.
So poverty.
Could keep you out of the system and if
for any reason you had not gone through
the algo gay from beginning to end
you were not a regular full Spartan.
Also if anybody had been
declared to be cowardly.
In fighting in the war that person could
be stricken from the rolls of Spartan
citizens and yet they
had no place else to go.
And so as we will see they lived a
rather wretched life in Sparta after that
situation similarly if people were
thought not to be the children of two
Spartans.
Spartan father Spartan mother
then they were not Sparta gates.
They held a and inferior place in that
society and in this society so riddled
with issues of honor and respect.
You can imagine that was a very big deal.
Keep that in the back of your mind
because as we move on the course and as we
get into the fifth century especially
we will be running into Spartans who fit
these categories who are not 100 percent
Spartans and yet some of them become
tremendously important and
powerful figures in Sparta
and we'll want to ask how
that happened.
But even more will want to ask how that
shaped the way they behaved once they
became important people now up to now
I've been talking about men but it's
important to talk about Spartan women too
because they were different from other
Greek women just as
the men were different.
I just.
Just to make that clear.
Let me make it plain that the rest
of the Greeks treated women very very
differently from men.
And one thing that was very striking and
the difference was that the men engaged
in physical exercise and these especially
in these competitions that were part
of the great games and those were always
carried out in the nude women did not
engage in these sports activities and
if it would have been that great the
greatest conceivable shame for a woman
to be seen in the nude it was just
absolutely unthinkable
for the ordinary Greeks.
But the Spartans do things their own way.
And their women engage in dancing and
athletics and in competition and they did
so in the nude just as the boys did and
so they were not shut away from the boys
all the time in the way that Greek
girls were kept away from the boys.
I don't mean to say they were allowed to
mingle socially but that is to say that
if the boys were exercising here the
girls might be exercising their someplace
else they would not be kept
so far apart from one another.
And I again think about all this all
of the things that normal human desires
think about it that that would get
excited in this kind of stuff that I've
been describing and yet they would never
have a crack at them until
they got to be 20 years old.
It all reminds me of a wonderful footnote
in a book about English history from
1914 to forty five by a J.P.
Taylor as some of the best
stuff is in his footnotes.
And this one says he was telling about.
The
the drop of the birth rate in Egypt.
Sorry England late 19th early 20th
century which he says was did was not
accompanied by a growth of knowledge
of or use of contraceptive devices.
And he concludes.
Anybody who studies England in this
period must deal must realize that he is
dealing with a deeply frustrated people.
Well if that's true of the British I mean
think of what life in Sparta was like
for a young man and young woman.
So on the one hand you have.
Women who are treated more like men in
Sparta than in other places and indeed
they even had greater legal rights
than they did in other states.
And I think all of that.
Kind of has.
Plays a part in the notion of degrading
the family as it is usually understood
in the Greek world and
elevating the notion of
a male dominated a male centered society
for the purpose of producing warriors.
Why are the women given this special
status because of the recognition that
women play a critical role in
producing the same kinds of warriors.
And that's what they're about.
One aspect of this to show you that it's
all for the Poles and it's all for the
business of producing good fighting men.
There were actually in a sense
group rights with the women.
For instance if a man found that his wife.
Couldn't bear children.
It was legal and proper and normal for
a man who was his friend to lend him his
wife and that the child who came from
that union would belong to the man who had
been childless.
Again I think I mean what is happening
to all the normal feelings about that
people have for one another.
And the central role that family plays
in almost every society you can think of.
So but on the other hand we
could not we should not imagine.
That women had a role in Spartan society
that was anything equal to them and
they would like in every
other part of the Greek world.
The women were excluded from
political life entirely.
And yet there are.
Well they kept it is
almost conflicting stuff.
Let me tell you the next thing I want
to tell you about the marriage ceremony.
In Sparta.
Shows you a very odd kind of a thing.
First of all it happened.
These are all ritual activities but you
ritually seize the girl you're going to
marry her.
It's as though you're you're saying that
the fundamental basic way you'll find a
family is you grab a woman
and she becomes yours.
Then this the marriage ceremony itself.
Girl has her head shaved.
And she is dressed as a man.
And sits in a darkened
room awaiting her groom.
And it seems to me that they're
trying to make her as much like a boy.
As they possibly can.
At this moment the conservation
of the marriage for the first time
well whatever my interpretation.
You've got to accept the weirdness of
the world that I have been describing to
you.
Well all of this you know had this
interesting impact the one other thing I
haven't told you that my last thing I
wanna say about women that went on when a
Spartan woman was a mother.
She was Pericles in his funeral oration
ends the humiliation to say now as to
the wives and mothers of these
great men who have just died.
Just shut up and go home.
Because.
The highest thing that can be said about
a woman is that she is never spoken of
for good or for ill. This is
democratic Athens we're talking about.
Well nobody ever told a Spartan mother
or to shut her mouth because Greek
literature is filled with
quotations from Spartan mothers
telling people stuff like telling their
son to go out to battle and come back
with your shield or on it.
You know that these shields were
like they were you could use them as.
What do you take bodies
out with no stretchers.
And so her message was you come back if
I heard you through your shield away and
ran don't come home.
And there are all kinds of tales.
So Spartan women obviously give me one
other one time late in their history when
things are going bad for the Spartans a
hostile army actually gets into Sparta
and the women are up there on the roofs
of their houses throwing roof tiles.
As projectiles against the enemy army.
So Spartan women were
really something else.
And there they are but if you
take the whole picture what is it.
It is as I say the degradation of the
family in favor of the importance of the
polis as a whole its needs and its.
Structure.
It is a warrior ethic.
It is based upon the principle
of the Hop light failings.
And I want to read to you a piece of
poetry written by the Spartan poet T.S.
was dated somewhere in the 7th century
that gets at a number of the topics I've
been talking about so far.
Here's how it goes.
I would not say anything for a man nor
take account of him for any speed of his
feet or wrestling skill he might have
not if he had the size of a Cyclops and
the strength to go with it not if he could
outrun Boris the north wind not if he
were more handsome and gracefully formed
than to owners or had more riches than
Midas had.
Or can I was to.
Not if he were more of a
king than tantalum peel or
has the power of speech and
persuasion that address does.
That is a catalogue of all the things
that people admire and want for themselves
and regard as important in Homer.
Everything.
Those are the characteristics that every
hero wants and he says I don't give a
damn for all that.
Says 30 is for no man.
I'm sorry I skipped an important line.
I don't care about any of those things.
Not if he had all splinters except for
a fighting spirit for no man ever proves
himself a good man in war unless he
can endure to face the blood and the
slaughter to go close against the
enemy and fight with his hands.
Here is our red tape which my translator
translates courage which is fair.
That's the most fundamental meaning of it.
But anyway it is the word retain.
Mankind's finest possession.
Here is the Nobel Peace Prize that a
young man can endeavour to win and it is a
good thing his city and all
the people share with him.
When a man plants his feet and
stands firm among the foremost Spears
relentlessly all sort of falls
like completely forgotten
and as well trained his
heart to be steadfast and endure and
with words encourages the man who is
stationed beside him.
Here is a man who proves himself
valiant in war with a sudden rush.
He turns to fight the rugged battalions
of the enemy and sustains the beating
wave of assault.
I don't care about any of those things
that you read about the Iliad The Odyssey.
All I care about is how do you
fight when you're in the Félix.
And if you don't have
it there you're nothing.
To continue.
He's not going to reexamine the
question of what happens if you die.
I mean that that happens doesn't it.
Here's what he says and he who so falls
among the champions and loses his sweet
life.
Notice that I want to touch that.
Here he is tell he's going to tell you
in a moment how good it is to die in this
way. But he's not kidding himself.
Life is sweet. You've lost it.
Here's that wonderful Greek real
realism that I told you about.
And loses his sweet life.
So blessing with honor his Polis his
father and all his people with wounds in
his chest.
Where the spear that he was facing has
transfixed the massive guard of his
shield and gone through
his breastplate as well.
Why such a man is lamented the like by
the young and the elders and all his city
goes into mourning and
grieves for his loss.
His tomb is pointed to with pride.
And so are his children.
And his children's children.
And afterward all the race that is his
his shining glory is never forgotten.
His name is remembered and
he becomes an immortal.
So he lies under the ground.
When one who was a brave man has been
killed by the furious war God standing his
ground and fighting hard for
his children and his land.
I hope you noticed all of the things we've
been talking about that are contained
in that statement.
All of those are reasons why you should
be willing to risk your life for your
policy because thereby you
can win yourself immortality
of one of the few ways
that you can do that as a Greek.
OK.
But he there is another
said what if things go well.
What if you don't get killed.
But if he escapes the doom of that death
the destroyer of bodies and wins his
battle.
And bright renown for the work of his
spear all men give place to him like.
The youth and the elders and much joy
comes his way before he goes down to the
dead.
Aging.
He has reputation among his citizens no
one tries to interfere with his honours
or all he deserves.
All men withdraw before his presence and
yield their seats to him the youth and
the men his age and even
those older than he.
Thus a man should endeavour to reach
this high plain place of courage with all
his heart and so trying
never be backward in war.
So it pays off for you to be brave and a
good soldier in the Phalanx whether you
live or die.
Both of them are good ends.
And notice how slyly he makes the point
about even if things go well for you
before you die.
Meaning don't imagine if you don't get
killed in this battle you're going to
live forever.
You're going to die anyway.
Now there was yet another element in
and by the way dirtiest witnesses songs
would have been the songs that the boys
would have been learned when but it
would have been taught in school and they
would have been marching along to the
music of that poem.
But then Xenophon who wrote late in the
5th early fourth centuries an Athenian
and knew the Spartans well as I say tells
us about how the Spartans dealt with
this problem of instilling courage in
their soldiers and the avoiding the
opposite.
Here's what he says in other
states when a man proves a coward.
The only consequence is
that he is called a coward.
He goes to the same market as the
brave man and sits beside him.
He attends the same gymnasium.
If he chooses but in Sparta everyone
would be ashamed to have a coward with him
at the mess or to be matched
with him in a wrestling bout.
Often when sides are picked for a game
of ball he is the odd man left out.
In a chorus he is banished
to the ignominious place.
In the streets he is bound to
make way when he occupies a seat.
He must needs give it up
even to a younger man.
He must support.
Get this his spinster relatives at home.
And he must explain to them why they
are old maids nobody is gonna marry the
sister of a coward and think of the joy.
Of.
Meeting your sister at home every day as
she looks at you and realizes she's not
going to have a husband because of you.
He must make the best of
a fireside without a wife
because who would marry such
a man and yet pay forfeit for that.
He may not stroll about with a cheerful
countenance if he walks around with a
smile on his face.
Somebody is going to knock it off.
Nor behave as though he were a man of
unsullied fame or else he must submit to
be beaten by his betters.
Small wonder I think.
Says Xenophon that where such a load
of dishonor is laid on the coward death
seems preferable to a life
so dishonored so ignominious.
Now the truth is I think
Xenophon is exaggerating.
I don't think it would be fun to come
home after behaving like a coward.
In any Greek city.
But I do think it's fair to say that
it would have been intolerable when if
you're talking about Sparta.
Yeah we have some time.
Let me turn now to the more
formal constitution of the
state as we would use the
term today.
It is
unique in Greek life.
It is a mixed constitution. It is
not a Democrat it is not a democracy.
It's not a monarchy. It's not an
oligarchy. It's not an aristocracy.
It contains elements of every one
of those more normal constitutions.
There are kings.
Notice I say plural because there are
two kings at any one time each descending
from a different royal family.
These kings have priestly
responsibilities they serve.
And this is very important as
generals who lead the Spartan army.
They are judges in all sorts of cases.
At any gathering of a public
nature they hold a seat of honor.
At banquets.
They get a double portion.
I don't think we should understand that
to mean that you get very big fat kings
so we twice as much as anybody else.
I think what this gives
them an opportunity to share
that with their friends and
to hand out honors and
to be thanked for that
when the Spartans appoint somebody to be
their representative in another state.
That's their form of diplomatic relations.
The man who appoints
the the the proxy in us.
That's the Greek word is that the Kings
make that appointment when the Spartans
have to consult the death Delphic oracle.
Men called the pithy oi are the ones who
are sent to make the enquiry and bring
back the answer.
The Kings select them.
Well these are of course enormously
honorific activities so the Kings are in a
position to hand out very important
honours to their fellow Spartans.
And that I think is another one of
the important privileges they have.
If there is an heiress who
does not have a husband.
This could be typically a woman whose
husband has died and now she needs to be
married to somebody else.
That.
Assignment is made by the Kings.
They tell that woman whom
she is going to marry.
The reason being behind that is that she
carries now because she has no brothers
no uncles who could inherit her father's
Clay Ross and other wealth that now
goes with her. She has to be assigned to
somebody on behalf of the Spartan state.
Likewise if there are
adoptions of children from one
family to another it is the
kings who make these decisions.
The Kings also sit on the council that
is the dominant advisory consulting
element in the whole Spartan state.
It is called the Guru S.R.
which would be translated into Latin as
sonata to us our words Senate it is a
council of elders it consists of twenty
eight men over the age of 60 who are
elected by the Spartans and the two kings
who sit with them to produce a council
of thirty.
The kingship is hereditary in each line.
With this little bump in it that is it's
not necessarily the first son of the
previous king. It's the first son
born after the king has become king.
So if there's any question about
that that's the determining element.
The Kings are the only Spartans who are
not required to go through the Argo gay.
I think the idea was it would be demeaning
for the royal figure to have to be
beaten up by older boys.
That's probably what's behind it.
On the other hand I think we should be
aware that these are. Even less than that.
Remember we spoke of the Greek.
Bacillus in early days as perhaps having
some kind of a royal function but never
a real one.
Well the Spartans have the power the
Spartan kings have the powers I've just
described but another thing that reduces
their kingly character is that there
are two of them.
That means one can always veto the other
and that means they never can have the
kind of power that a true
king in our sense would have.
One other thing is that two other
things one is that the Garrow C.R.
this council of elders has very important
powers and some and some of them
relating to the Kings.
There is another group of Spartans
another council and annual accounts.
I should've told you that the galaxy.
Once the men are chosen they serve for
life but there is another council in
Sparta of men five of them called F wars
and these f wars are ordinary Spartans
who come from the just from any anybody
who is a Spartan one of the powers they
have is of the Kings is they can bring
charges against the Kings if they believe
that the either of the Kings has done
wrong violated the law done something
improper and then the Kings
are tried by the group seal
and then if you think that's just a pro
forma activity the Spartan history is
filled with kings who have been convicted
of some crime or other and are driven
off into exile and
removed from the kingship.
So these are very powerful limitations.
I think I'm out of time so I'll I'll
start next time by completing our
discussion of the Spartan state
and move forward from there.